I came to get a general
business grounding and
the core curriculum does
an excellent job of that.
But what's fantastic about our curriculum
is we can choose more than half of it
to really focus on what's
important to us as individuals.
And that's a really special
thing about the MSx Program.
I've loved the academic experience, yeah.
So it's obvious we're coming to business
school, we're going to be in class for
most of our time during the day.
And I really just like the caliber and
the thought that goes into our curriculum.
And one of the reasons I came to
the GSB was really to broaden my
business knowledge.
And I feel that GSB has
really surpassed that for me.